it's a girl for Rob Kardashian and blac  Chyna I'm happy and we're excited  the couple is expecting their first  child together and a new heiress to the  Kardashian Throne China is already the  proud mama to King Cairo her  three-year-old son with ex Tyga I felt  my baby the pair is keeping busy filming  their upcoming reality show of robbing  China are you excited I'm excited yes  but I know you guys are probably feel  really weird I mean I don't expect you  guys to be all happy the Kardashian  sisters have come a long way from the  initial shock china told ET in June that  all is well with Rob's entire family  we're all in a good place and I'm happy  and we're excited for the new addition  in my family and in their family